how's it going bros my another day
another go talk better morning to you
sorry we're gonna play some more goat at
my mouth hell yah what am i cool yet I
like the background they selected it's
just a [ __ ] road
alright we played us tank with players
rogue we players microwave repairs
Hunter it's time to play it's magician
baby and get stop stop molesting me
again
I swear to God I don't care how cute you
are alright so now we're with it oh
there's an hourglass watch these boots
these food these shoes man I can jump so
high oh my god it's amazing step aside
lady there's an hour ago ah oh no the
bookshelves anything anything but the
book ships alright let's check out our
Jesus what are you doing what are you
doing buddy let's check out our new
abilities all right goat sees that's
right eat eat all my cards make it rain
make it rain make it rain on them house
alright that's amazing it doesn't do
anything how about this one I can shoot
fireballs Wow damn I can shoot far ha
nice spoons why the hell would you need
that many spoons I'm so glad I have a
spoon ow
alright I'm looking for potato chips and
mon Dieu yes of course yes of course I'm
a magician yes yes damnit Omar said the
game are die where's all the Mountain
Dew and Doritos yes I slick all my mind
ooh what up ah no don't ride me you
dirty [ __ ] em where the hell is all the
Mountain Dew I'm looking everywhere
Jesus who hides all the Mountain Dew
there we go that's my Mountain
dammit um and in dude no all right how
much you want for the Doritos I shall
pay you handsomely in cards make it rain
I'm that ho make it rain I'm making it
rain on you girl appreciate there you go
that's it twerk for me baby are ye there
you go 50 pence shillings for some
Mountain Dew thank you
sorry hahaha come on one more
ah there's one yes yes yes yes
yes yes wizard I am now a wizard I'm
taking all the sponsorships go to old
goat mountain and seek out your nemesis
mighty goat but I never met him how can
he be my nemesis all right I shall not
question you oh mighty king Lord who is
so worthy that's right
you are so worthy of that that throne
defeat the old goat in old goat mountain
let's go bro whoa they're taking the
hobbits to Isengard here we are this is
a new area oh my god oh my god old goat
pass oh my god well what Oh wet frickin
ah
oh my god it's high level goat sirs they
really know how to farm those demons
what do we do I'm a fire this girl is on
fire got you now [ __ ]
whoo ah bad idea abort abort what what
the hell I just I just went through the
portal oh my god and it wins ah no no
please make it stop
oh we made it I think God stupid flag
what we got the Apple ah ah thank God
good thing I'm a goat and I'm okay
mortal lease what have I done did is
Jennifer I'm disappointed
where am I supposed to go but if I lick
it and then put it yep so smart so smart
okay uh yeah just do your worst
ah I needed a I needed a back massage
thank you
all right you can stop now it's not
funny anymore
ah hi the t-rex don't mind me just gonna
come and steal your [ __ ] oh no oh no
he's cookie sobbing now remember Bruce
if a t-rex spicy you have to stand still
how do you hold that cutlery let's make
any sense brother I'll thank God we got
the last hourglass oh my god sorry I
just need your butter don't kill me
now I stopped eating mate damn it and
make me kill you breath get leg
get rekt get t-rex get it Wow Emma J old
goat so he was - all go in the mountain
the legend foretold I have to bring him
with me as evidence I feel bad for him
he was just trying to eat his butter and
I'd [ __ ] murder him
what Duff is his bathroom ah he pooped
out a hole Salman
he didn't even flush what a dirty ho oh
there we go I flushed oh god oh god no
what I sold this I am so confused
he dropped a demon horn yes oh my god
we're on a freaking roller Bros this is
amazing are those baguettes goodbye old
goat I love you with all my heart I wish
we could make babies
little goat babies together front flip
I'm born every said and I shall die a
wizard yeah like I'm not a wizard I'm a
magician
ha ha hi first we live in the merlok
quest
sorry mermaid quest I figured out what
you wanted to Queen blog you wanted the
hourglass you wanted time back
today's when you were not so [ __ ]
ugly oh sorry I didn't know you had a
fetish [ __ ] the way leaving the Quinn
there we go that's how it's done
let me oh yeah baby we're back in the
land of mermaids there's such beautiful
vibrant creatures
I really don't Oh traffic traffic
traffic Daria Merriman's maids woman
whatever they can't all be mermaids
right there has to be some romance in
there I mean how else do they get babies
and actually scratch that I don't want
to know
let's kill give gandalf can deaf oh no
sorry it was Dumbledore Dumbledore John
mr. horn
doesn't even make sense portal 2 reaches
what does he work
stop hitting man yes yes treble yes oh
my [ __ ] god money no what is that
Wilson [ __ ] Wilson Wilson I have so
many questions
goats and it's good huh what the [ __ ]
all right well I guess I guess this is
my throw now well this has been great I
hope you guys enjoyed watching what do
we do if I jump up hail thank you thank
you can I go home now mom I want to go
home now mom hey I don't want to be a
wizard anymore
I changed my mind okay here we go how do
I get back
seriously okay there's supposed to be
sugar in this town he's head
oh hello I'll take you thank you there's
the [ __ ] sugar oh my god if only I
knew if only I knew it was so close
you're gonna just start it yourself
oh you stupid dancing [ __ ] all right
here you go it looks like we did all the
quest dammit I want to play ma let's go
and look for some nice rings all right
take me it's gonna take me somewhere
your knees are on fire man your frickin
knees are on fire what it what what are
you dude calm down
ah no hang on goatey this is ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha oh oh Jesus guys where are
we going buddy
aah aah Queen blog hello hello that's
the best ride of my life
all right press I think that's it I
think we discovered most of stuff hope
it was appreciated that I went really
in-depth with this please leave like you
enjoyed watching this series with me I
had so much fun playing thank you both
seriously stay awesome